[Music]
hey what's up um here okay there's a
book called the myth of fair value
and in that book it's all about pricing
strategies for different products and
things like that and in that there's a
study that they go over about purchasing
patterns so in test number one a company
selling a product offers a regular
option and a premium option and four out
of five people pick the more premium one
so then in test number two they added a
third cheaper option to see if they
could maybe increase revenue by looping
in an audience that's looking for a
cheaper lowest possible price
turned out the cheapest option was kind
of just ignored but it completely
flipped the ratio of standard to premium
purchases because now people would
assume that the middle one was the
appropriate value so then in test number
three they took away the cheap option
but then added an ultra premium option
over the top
and this ended up flipping the ratio
right back to the original premium one
but also some portion of people just
went with the more expensive one just
because that's what they want and so
this ended up with the highest overall
revenue generated pricing ladders are
very real and very much designed to get
you to spend as much as possible and
make those companies as much money as
they can this
is the new 2022 ipad air with the new m1
chip inside you can tell because it's a
nice shiny deeper blue color
it's nice but it is one of the stranger
apple products that i've seen in a long
time because of its price and where it
sits in the lineup
because it kind of messes with the
ladder a little bit so look it's
actually very simple to understand what
you're getting here with this spec bump
which is an even more powerful version
of the ipad we already know i already
reviewed the 2020 ipad air and i'll link
that below the like button so you
already know what you're getting on the
outside and then i've already reviewed
several computers with the m1 chip
including the ipad pro with this m1 so
you know what you're getting on the
inside too
this is a thin 11 inch tablet
same exact dimensions as the last ipad
air so those cases all still work your
single camera on the back usb type c at
the bottom the touch id fingerprint
reader in the power button up in the
corner and the 11 inch 60 hertz display
up front running the exact same ipad os
as every other ipad the reason it's so
strange is this is the most i've ever
seen one apple product seem to overlap
another
that other product being the ipad pro so
the last ipad air was already very close
to the ipad pro right it had basically
the same dimensions same exact camera
same battery life and the same software
features of all the other most expensive
ipads it works with the same 2nd gen
apple pencil it's just as thin in my
review i called it the one true ipad pro
killer because it's 80 of the tablet for
200 less dollars and so this year now
that the new ipad air also gets the
incredible massively overkill new m1
chip inside it's one more thing that
they do exactly the same so the ipad air
starts at 5.99 and the 11 inch ipad pro
starts at 7.99
but let's take a closer look at this
pricing see this is a pricing ladder
after all so it's designed to have
something available at every price and
then every time you arrive at one price
there's something a little higher to try
to nudge you up and try to get you as
high in that ladder as they can so the
base price ipad air is only a 64
gigabyte ipad for 600 bucks in 2022
that's not really great i mean we got 20
gig games today so of course the only
available storage option is straight up
to 256 gigs which is 150 extra dollars
so now you're playing in the 750
territory which is a lot of money to
spend on an air when for just fifty
dollars more
you can get a pro right so now you might
as well just bump up to the ipad pro so
you can see what they're doing right
they're nudging you up a little bit by a
little bit but the thing is
the ipad pro
is more expensive but it's almost the
same tablet in so many ways so they're
already practically the same dimensions
to the point where the ipad air works in
all the same cases and keyboards that
the ipad pro works in they're the same
primary camera on the back the same usb
c port the same battery life and now the
same m1 chip so you'd have to think
extra hard about spending extra money on
an ipad pro when the list of reasons to
do so is smaller than ever before now as
someone who's used both tablets honestly
one of those reasons is pretty huge
and then the rest
are all pretty minor but let's just go
through each of them so the only reason
i still pick an ipad pro as a better
overall experience a better tablet than
the air is the pro motion display so
they're about the same size and
resolution but the faster 120hz refresh
rate is one of those things that just
makes everything about using the pro
smoother and snappier and more
responsive and that's the thing that
makes the m1 chip in this ipad air so
funny which is it theoretically closes
the gap in performance versus the pro
with you know rendering and exporting
and compiling and things like that
but it does not feel
as fast
because of the 60 hertz so those big
animations where your hand moves across
the entire screen the unlock animation
the multitasking gestures the big stuff
like that you could put a 30 90 in here
and it wouldn't feel as smooth as the
pro motion ipad now sure some people
need to see them side by side and even
then they barely see a difference in
which case yeah that person should just
get the ipad air but i'm telling you for
me if you're like me
that's something i would spend the extra
money for but then the ipad pro has one
extra camera the 10 megapixel ultra wide
plus a lidar scanner and a flash the
ipad air just has a single camera no
flash so you know for the occasional
video call or document scanning that's
totally fine for me and like i said it's
the same main camera as the ipad pro so
there isn't even a quality difference
here then the ipad pro has quad speaker
audio instead of the dual speakers of
the ipad air they're both very solid
speakers and it's definitely a bit
fuller and louder from the pro but
that's not something you're going out
and spending extra money on specifically
and then the pro has a higher max
storage so you can go up to 2 terabytes
instead of just 256 gigs and the usb-c
port is thunderbolt on the pro instead
of just faster usbc
on the air so that might open up some
potential peripheral options for actual
pros plugging in drives etc and then of
course you have face id on the ipad pro
where you've got the touch id
fingerprint reader on the ipad air
honestly at this point
it's kind of preference like you get
used to having face id on the tablet
very quickly when you have it but also
the good old-fashioned two fingers
registered on the ipad air works really
well too so in portrait it's the right
index finger that unlocks and then in
landscape it's the left index finger
great you know what's funny though the
only other update to the air besides the
m1 chip being inside is the selfie
camera is now the ultra wide with center
stage so it's got the newer
selfie camera and it's convenient it
follows you around the room it's kind of
in an awkward location but it's decently
smooth with face time zoom calls etc but
because the ipad pro has the face id
sensors and stuff technically only that
older selfie camera will support
animojis
and memojis and things like that
so there's that but that's basically it
right that's the differences so now
hearing that list you probably already
know if you would be tempted to move up
one more rung on that ladder you know
maybe 50 extra bucks for promotion does
it for you like it does it for me or
maybe you just want a larger tablet
because you do have the 13 inch ipad pro
with mini led if you're tempted to go
large but other than that you know the
extra camera lidar
the face id the speakers
all pretty minor things but then the
funniest part usually right the ladders
are designed to try to nudge you up to
try to get you to spend more and more
money
putting one of the features from the
more expensive model in the less
expensive model
just removes one reason to upgrade and
may actually
encourage a small number of people
to move down because now that
theoretical person who would have spent
the extra money to get the hugely
improved processing power of the m1
now just has one less reason to get the
pro they can get it in the air well that
is until the m2 version comes out anyway
either way it's fascinating it's always
interesting to see these new products
come out at these different various
price ranges i think in that example
from the beginning of the video you know
apple clearly has a baseline ipad an
ipad air and an ipad pro
and most people don't need to spend the
extra money to get the most premium ipad
pro i think the promotion is enough just
for me and a lot of people would too but
there's also going to be a bunch of
people that just spend the extra money
just because they want the most premium
thing
fine but this ipad air is another great
spec bump
that actually makes me even more
frustrated that ipad os
is not evolving to fully take advantage
of it but that's a another rant for
another video either way that's been it
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace